Wir blicken heute in der Ligatour unter anderem auf Marseille, Napoli, Almeria und – wir wollen natürlich auch noch mal kurz sprechen – über die Fanproteste in der Liga und ob sowas in den anderen Ligen wohl denkbar werde. Jetzt gleich mit Nils Kern, David Frogier de Ponlevoy, Marius Soyke und Uli Hebel gibt's später auch noch zu hören.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ich grüße euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, und ich grüße meine Runde. Wir beginnen mit einem Thema aus der Bundesliga. Ihr habt es ja alle mitbekommen, die Fanproteste in der Bundesliga, unter anderem die Fanproteste haben dazu geführt und die Diskussion danach, dass es jetzt keinen Investoreneinstieg gibt. Sehr fantastisches Timing von der DFL. Wir haben gerade zwei Stunden bevor diese Meldung kam, die Sendung veröffentlicht zum Deal aus Investorensicht. Ich glaube allerdings, dass man die immer noch sehr gut hören kann. Also dieses Tribüngespräch hat auch schon viel Resonanz bekommen. Also hört es euch gerne mal an. Man versteht dann nämlich, dass die Probleme jetzt nicht weggehen werden, die es aktuell in der Liga gibt. Und ich glaube, es ist auch gar nicht so schlecht zu wissen, wie CWC so funktioniert. Denn die hängen ja bei zwei von drei von euch drin. Und bei der Serie A, da klopfen sie ja immer noch an. Deswegen würde ich gerne mal einsteigen. Nils, nimmt man denn in La Liga wahr, was gerade da Antennisbällen aufs Feld geflogen ist in der Bundesliga und wäre sowas in Spanien auch denkbar?
Aber haben wir dich auch schon erlebt, welche Auswirkungen das konkret hat? Also klar, man könnte jetzt quasi noch nachträglich bestraft werden, dass man in dieser Saison drüber liegt, aber solange man drüber liegt, darf man doch keine neuen Spieler registrieren. War das nicht das Vorgehen bisher?
Genau, das ist das Vorgehen immer auch gewesen. Speziell im Sommer haben da viele Vereine auch Bettys, die dann erst am letzten Deadline-Day 4, 5 oder 6 Spieler doch noch eintragen konnten, speziell Neuzugänge oder Spieler, die gerade frisch ihren Vertrag verlängert haben, also wo es auch zu Gehaltserhöhungen kam, dass da viele Vereine Probleme haben, die Spieler zu registrieren. Schlussendlich schaffen es trotzdem alle klar, weil auch da noch mal einer abgegeben wird oder dann wird doch noch einer als Jugendspieler gemeldet. Da gibt es schon viele Tricks, speziell wenn man sich natürlich auch Leihspieler holt, wo dann teilweise das Gehalt noch vom Stammverein abgegeben wird. Oder bei Joao Felix gab es den Trick zum Beispiel, der wurde für einen Mini-Gehalt unter Vertrag genommen, also von Athletico zu Barca ausgeliehen. 400.000 Euro, glaube ich, Gehalt. Das hat dann noch ins Salary Cap damals gepasst. Und dann einen Monat später, als das Salary Cap veröffentlicht wurde, heißt es auf einmal, ja, der hat so gute Leistung, wir verzehnfachen jetzt sein Gehalt. Da kam die Gehaltserhöhung.
Ja, Salary Cap funktioniert auf die lange Dauer. Nie hat er in der Bundesliga nicht funktioniert. Hat noch in keiner Liga wirklich funktioniert, außer man hat eben ein geschlossenes System wie NFL und so weiter. Und selbst da ist es ja so, dass die Art und Weise, wie der noch oben, dann gibt es das ein bisschen Einschränk. Aber jetzt wissen wir endlich, was den 1. FC Köln mit Barca verbindet. Oder natürlich andersrum. Beide können im Sommer keine Spieler registrieren. Ja, aber interessant. Und vor allem die Zahlen zu hören, ist wirklich interessant. Weil es macht ja, ich finde, wenn man das so quasi so live in Anführungszeichen bekommt, während der laufenden Saison, das ist halt ein super Hintergrund, den man neben die aktuelle Tabelle legen kann. Weil eben der Personalaufwand halt schon mit Tabellenplatzierung korreliert zumindest grob. Und wenn man dann sieht, ich meine, jetzt ist real 6 Punkte weg von Girona. Haben wir ja auch schon thematisiert. Dann sieht man ja, okay, das sollte aber halt auch so sein. Ansonsten anderperformen die sehr deutlich. Und bei anderen wiederum sieht man, die machen mehr aus ihren aktuellen Möglichkeiten. Und das finde ich gut. Das finde ich besser, als irgendwie immer mit einem Jahr Verzögerung die Zahlen von der DFL zu bekommen, aus der man dann aber ganz viele Dinge gar nicht so wirklich rauslesen kann.
Kann man, muss ich bestimmt auch an der Stelle dann mal loben. Alaves und Las Palmas haben mit das kleinste Budget, aber sind eben als beste Aufsteiger auf den Plätzen 9, Las Palmas und 12. Alaves, die spielen beide eine super Saison, sind heimstark und so weiter. Unangenehm spielerisch, aber trotzdem auch gut, ohne dass sie jetzt nur mauern. Also die machen viel draus. Und weil du Girona angesprochen hast, ich glaube, die haben mit, was waren es, 42 Millionen Budget, das ist auch unter den letzten 5 Plätzen. Ja, die überperformen halt natürlich, weil sie, wie gesagt, hier und da ein paar Leihspiele haben, wo sie nicht so viel Gehalt zahlen müssen.
Ja, wobei sie ansonsten ganz gut finanziell aufgestellt sein sollen. Da hat Swiss Ramble neulich die Finanzanalyse zugepostet, also 46 Prozent gehören der Citigroup, dann irgendwie 17 Prozent des Vereins gehören dem Bruder von Pep Guardiola, der ja quasi da unterwegs ist. Und aber ganz viel von den Einnahmen, die sie haben, kommen eben aus Sponsoring und so weiter. Also sie arbeiten quasi auf einem gesunden wirtschaftlichen Level und bekommen dann dazu natürlich noch sportliche Qualität von City. Das würde ich jetzt auch kritisieren. Aber es ist jetzt quasi nicht so, dass sie quasi so komplett künstlich hochgezogen würden, sondern die agieren schon relativ vernünftig in einem wirtschaftlichen Rahmen.
Und auch da haben wir auch gute Scout-Diggen mit Atendorfbeg, das wird auch viel Gutes gemacht.
Also wirklich ganz interessant. Und Las Palmas, das haben vielleicht einige mitbekommen, die haben Real doch so ein gutes Heimspiel geliefert. War das nicht relativ knapp, dass Real da gewonnen hat? Zwei, eins, genau, erst hinten raus.
Ja, auch nach Rückstand mal wieder.
Genau, genau, aber gut, das ist ja für Real egal und läuft ja eh alles.
Erst dann wird es spannend.
Ja, ja, komm, erst ab Champions-League-Finale wird es interessant. Das wird ja quasi die Saison eines Realtrainers, das wird ja nach dem Abschneiden im Champions-League-Finale bewertet. Deswegen müssen wir da noch ein bisschen warten. Also das ist der neue Salary Cap in La Liga. Und bevor wir zu den Awards kommen, schauen wir nochmal in die Premier League. Uli, was magst du uns da noch als zweites Thema präsentieren?
Ich glaube, das zweite ist einigermaßen naheliegend. Oliver Glasner, wir haben ja schon mal ganz kurz von der Gruppe gehört. Aber das ist, glaube ich, sehr naheliegend. Das ist jetzt nicht zwingend positiv. Das heißt, ich breche mit meiner auferlegten Idee, wobei ich es dann doch irgendwie sehr positiv finde für Crystal Palace. Das ist, glaube ich, ein echter Stil, diesen Trainer bekommen zu haben. Und der hat jetzt Dienstag dann seine Dienste aufgenommen, obwohl er schon eine ganze Zeit lang, glaube ich, da war im Süden Londons. Muss man oder kommt man, glaube ich, nicht aus, ohne ein halbes Wort zu Roy Hodgson zu verlieren. Wir haben ja jetzt schon einmal hier über ihn gesprochen und die Gründe, warum das alles gerade nicht so läuft. Jetzt ist er 76, ist am vergangenen Donnerstag auf dem Trainingsplatz zusammengebrochen. Das ist das, was ich weiß. Und der Kollege, der da war, hat mir nur gesagt, es war wirklich so, dass einige echt schockiert waren. Und allein im Sinne der Gesundheit ist es dann vielleicht auch ganz gut, dass er tatsächlich sich jetzt mal eine Ruhepause gönnt. Ich würde noch nicht sagen, dass er seine Trainer-Karriere beendet, weil ich das glaube ich einfach noch nicht. Aber zumindest, dass er jetzt mal für das Erste eine kleine Pause aus gesundheitlichen Gründen dann auch einlegen kann. Absolut verdienter Mann, Meister Premier League-Spieler bei Crystal Palace, kommt ja auch aus dem Borough of Croydon. Das ist immer sein Verein gewesen. Auch deshalb hat er sich noch ein zweites Mal hinreißen lassen, um ihn zu retten. Vielleicht war es dann am Ende ein halbes Jahr zu viel. Da ist er dann auch wieder, der schon genannte John Texter. Der wollte ihn wohl schon im Dezember, als wir hier drüber gesprochen haben, gerne ablösen. Er gab vor allen Dingen Sorge, dass das Training zu wenig intensiv gewesen sei und dass Roy Watson sich selbst hier und da mal im Kopf und Kragen redet. Das hat er jetzt dann final getan. Auch aufgrund der Intensität haben sie dann Oliver Glasner letzten Mittwoch als absoluten Wunschkandidaten ausgemacht. Da hat mich der besagte Kollege ganz hektisch angerufen und gesagt, wir müssen alles zu Glasner sagen. Da habe ich noch gesagt, das wird nie passieren, der geht da nicht hin.
Warum hast du das gedacht?
Weil ich mit ihm ganz lange drüber gesprochen hatte, wie der nächste Club aussehen sollte. Und alles, was er da beschrieben hat, ist nicht Crystal Palace. Das hat mir also sehr gewundert, dass er das dann tatsächlich gemacht hat, auch wenn ich den Reiz natürlich schon verstehen kann.
Ja, gut. Ich meine, dazu gehört vielleicht, dass Uli Glasner mutmaßlich das nicht die erste Möglichkeit war, in die Premier League zu wechseln und der letzte Verein, der da eventuell mit einer Rolle gespielt hat, jetzt aktuell Tabellenvierter ist. Vielleicht spielt das damit rein, dass man das Gefühl hat, jetzt will ich nicht noch eine Möglichkeit verstreichen lassen.
Ja, mir hat auch ein anderer Kollege gesagt, dass er tatsächlich auch bei Nottingham von sich aus schon vorgesprochen haben soll, als die nun Respetto Santo dann genommen hatten anstelle Steve Coopers. Auch das ist nur Mutmaßung, ich weiß das nicht. Habe ich nicht mit ihm darüber gesprochen. Das wäre also jetzt falsch, auch nur in die Entfernung zu gehen. Ich denke, dass sich vielleicht Kemp Glasner insgesamt ausgerechnet haben könnte, dass er vielleicht bei mehr Positionen genannt werden würde für potenzielle Nachfolgen. Mal abgesehen davon, dass es gar nicht so viele dieser Positionen gab in der Saison, die frei geworden wären. Die Champions League-Aspiranten haben gar nicht gewechselt, weder in der Premier League noch auch in der Bundesliga zum Beispiel, wo es irgendwie naheliegend wäre. Ich sage jetzt nochmal, hätte Oliver Glasner sich vielleicht gedacht, Dortmund wäre okay gewesen, vermutlich. Aber die haben halt nicht gewechselt zum Beispiel.
Wer wollte auf Bayern nicht warten?
Wäre auch denkbar, muss man schon ehrlich sagen. Es ist auch eine komische Woche, in der das tatsächlich passiert. Ich glaube, dass man wahrscheinlich gemerkt hat, wir werden nicht so konstant genannt, wenn es Nachfolger suchen gibt, wie wir dachten, dass wir es werden. Wäre wahrscheinlich auch anders gewesen, wenn im letzten Sommer der Europapokal nach Frankfurt gewandert wäre und nicht im Jahr davor. So sind schon einige Red Flags hochgegangen, ob des Verhaltens hinten raus bei Eintracht Frankfurt. Da gab es auch mehrere Nachfragen dazu von einigen Kollegen, die gesagt haben, wie war das exakt. Das ist so meine ganz eigene Herleitung, wie es zu Crystal Palace gekommen ist. Neben dem, dass ich denke, dass er echt einiges an Macht bekommen wird. Vom Status, vom Namen her waren auch die englischen Kollegen echt verwundert, dass der das macht. Wenn wir ehrlich sind, Platz 12 ist das Maximum. Oder 11, keine Ahnung. Aber da muss schon alles ideal laufen. Ich glaube, mehr geht auch nicht.
Ach, krass. Aber er hat vielleicht auch keine andere Wahl als zu Crystal Palace zu gehen. Ich meine, da spielt Cagiro Riedewald und das ist so nah an Frankfurt-Riedewald, da musste er ja hin.
Den finde ich sehr gut, muss ich sagen. Vielleicht als Referenzclown.
Sehr gut. Aber was ist von dem Kader zu erwarten? Du hast jetzt schon gesagt, Stil aus Sicht von Crystal Palace. Gleichzeitig hast du gesagt, also maximal vier Plätze nach oben geht es noch, weil sie sind aktuell 15. Du hast 11 als Dach so ein bisschen angesprochen. Was ist zu erwarten?
Ja, also wie immer, Glasner wird dem Team beibringen, dass sie seriös spielen, wenig zulassen und ins Umschalten gehen. Das ist auch im Grunde das, was Roy Ortschneier auch getan hat. Nur, dass sie jetzt einfach viel zu viele Gegentore kassiert haben. Auch aufgrund von Verletzungen, teilweise die Defensive nicht beieinander hatten. Ich glaube schon, dass da ein paar Spieler drin sind, die Glasner echt mag. Mir fehlt nach wie vor Wilfrid Zaha, der das einzige Outlet war in der letzten Saison. Da hat er schon seinen 4-4-2-Umschalt-Fußball durchziehen können. Der fehlt halt einfach mit seiner Qualität. Den haben sie nie ersetzen können. Die, die da sind, die Klasse haben wie Ebrechi Ese oder Michael Ulisse, die sind entweder zusammenverletzt oder abwechselnd. Also können kaum miteinander spielen, wenn sie drauf waren. Es gab mal eine kleine Phase Mitte Dezember. Dann sieht man sofort, okay, die sind da und die sind echt gut. Und wenn Glasner die hinbekommt, auch, dass sie gesund bleiben, dann hat er schon die Chance, dass er eben nach oben wandert. Und das ist dann auch wieder Herleitung 2.0, dass ich denke, dass Glasner sich aller Hasenhüttel in der Premier League dann beweisen will und zeigen kann, ich kann die zweimal konstant auf der 11 halten. Und jetzt kommt mal ihr, weiß ich nicht, Aston Villas oder Brightons oder wie sie alle heißen, die dann irgendwann mal sicherlich auch mal wieder einen Trainerschwund erleben werden. Aber der Kader ist gealtert wieder. Sie haben ihn stark verjüngt, als Patrick Villara gekommen ist. Sie haben sich ganz stark auf den immer selben Spielertyp gesetzt, also im Grunde Ahamada in allen Formen, auf jeder Position. Ein großgewachsen, athletisch sehr cleverer Spieler, der aber extrem viel Potenzial aufweisen muss, weil er an einzelnen Punkten noch wahnsinnig roh ist. Das haben sie dann die ganze Zeit gemacht, dass sie da jünger geworden sind, athletischer geworden sind. Im Verlaufe jetzt sind aber einige schon wieder weg davon und es sind die immer Alten da geblieben. Das heißt, das Durchschnittsalter ist durchaus wieder gestiegen. Wie immer, bei solchen Clubs geht im Sommer kleine Qualität nur, weil es immer nur 1-2 sind, aber die gehen natürlich logischerweise nicht. Ich rechne ehrlich gesagt auch mit dem eigenen Abgang im Sommer. Also Mark Gahey wird dann nicht bleiben. Hoffe ich zumindest auch für ihn, weil er muss anderswohin. Er ist echt ein guter Mann. Ich bin bei Ullise gespannt, ob sie den halten können. Der war ja schon im Sommer so gut wie bei Manchester City. Der wird sicherlich auch weitere Angebote bekommen. Esser ist einer der Dribbler der Liga. Auch da tippe ich, dass sich jemand für den interessieren wird. Tarik Mitchell auf links Verteidiger ist einer dieser Athleten, der weitergehen wird und dann gibt es noch ein paar unzufriedene Spieler auch oben drauf, die jetzt nicht das Grau d Fett machen. Aber Kader ist Platz 12 bis 14 mit Glasner. Ohne Glasner halt 15.
Dann sind wir mal gespannt, ob vielleicht Jean-Philippe Mathéter der neue Zielstürmer wird. Das mag ja Rafa auch ganz gerne.
Das ist einer der angesprochenen Unzufriedenen. Der muss sich ziemlich daneben bedommen haben im letzten halben Jahr.
Ich werde dazu nichts weiter sagen, sondern leite ganz galant in die Awards über, die wir noch besprechen wollen, in allen Ligen. Ich glaube, am längsten musste jetzt David schweigen. Deswegen darf er loslegen mit seinem MVP.
Mein MVP ist einer von zwei Spielern in der Liga, die mehr Tore als Spiele haben. Und zwar nicht, wie es gerade hieß, der gewisse Franzose. Der hat nämlich auch 21 Tore in 20 Spielen.
Das ist auch ganz stark, das bei der Besprechung der Ligue 1 zu sagen.
Also wir reden jetzt nicht über einen gewissen Franzosen, aber trotzdem wissen wir alle, wer gemeint ist. Sondern Mohamed Bamba. Der hat 5 Tore in 4 Spielen. Der spielt für Lorient, kommt aus der Elfenbeinküste, ist jetzt im Winter vom Volkswagen AC aus Österreich rüber gewechselt. Für immerhin stolze 5 Millionen. Klingt aber jetzt mit seinen aktuellen Toren durchaus wie ein Schnäppchen. Hat sich da wunderbar eingefügt. Seine 5 Tore hat er übrigens aus 2 XG erzielt. Also ich weiß, Max, du bist ja immer skeptisch, was so gewisse Statistiken angeht. Aber es zeigt zumindest, dass er seine Tore aus vergleichsweise unwahrscheinlichen Situationen auch noch reinhaut.
Also Thomas Tuchel ist Fan, das kann ich sagen.
Gleichzeitig durchaus auch noch in Zweikillinflaviert. Macht einen guten Eindruck. Und Lorient ist jetzt erstmal diese Saison nicht auf dem Abstiegsplatz.
Sehr, sehr schön. Den nehmen wir doch gerne. Marius, wen möchtest du gerne als MVP nominieren?
Ich habe da mitgebracht Lorenzo Pellegrini, den Kapitän der Roma. Der unter Mourinho, glaube ich, dass die größte Differenz zwischen dem, was er kann und zwischen dem, was er gezeigt hat, aufgewiesen hat in der gesamten Liga. Also einer der talentiertesten Mittelfeldspieler für mich der Serie A. Und einer, der auch eine tragende Rolle in das Quadra Azura spielen sollte. Aber zwischen ihm und Mourinho hat es mit dem System, das er da spielen lassen, hat irgendwie nie so richtig gepasst. Und jetzt ist ja Mourinho bekanntermaßen seit der Niederlage gegen Milan weg. Und Daniele De Rossi ist da, mit dem Pellegrini selbst noch zusammengespielt hat. Und unter dem hat er jetzt in sechs Spielen, da haben sie nur eins von verloren gegen Inter, waren auch nicht die schwersten Gegner, also tabellarisch gesehen zumindest. Immerhin auch 1-1 in Rotterdam im Europa League Playoff. Da geht es dann heute Abend ins Rückspiel. Und er hat da drei Tore, drei Vorlagen in sechs Spielen. Und zeigt endlich seit Jahren eigentlich mal wieder, war auch viel verletzt, aber zeigt endlich mal wieder das, was die Fans von einem Sohn der Stadt, also dem legitim Nachfolger von Totti und De Rossi, wenn man so will, auch wenn er nicht so das große Star ansehen hat weltweit, was sie davon immer warten. Und das finde ich sehr erwähnenswert.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen die Herzgeschichte aus der Serie A.
Genau.
Also noch mehr als der Trainer bei Napoli. Aber das ist schon irgendwie, da kommt De Rossi und auf einmal trifft Pellegrini wieder.
Und die Oma klettert halt so langsam nach oben. Jetzt sind es noch vier Punkte auf Bologna aktuell Rang 6. So sieht es aus. Nils, wen magst du uns aus La Liga präsentieren?
Ich würde mal aufgrund einer Diskussion rund um die Nationalmannschaft mal erklären, warum Toni Kroos wirklich eine sehr, sehr gute Saison spielt bei Real Madrid. Jetzt nicht nur, weil er in der Liga keiner noch mehr Vorlagen hat als er. Ich glaube, wenn es darum geht zu Pässe ins letzte Drittel, da können nur Chaka und Rodri seine Zahlen matchen. Da ist er herausragend, natürlich lange Bälle, Seitenverlagerung. Das hat er immer noch drauf. Aber speziell finde ich auch spannend, dass er schon in den letzten Jahren, seit dem Casemiro-Abgang, sich auch defensiv noch mal gesteigert hat. Fast ein bisschen mit Lust und Spaß in Zweikämpfe geht. Ich habe ihn letztens bei der Pressekonferenz in Leipzig auch gefragt, woher das so kommt. Er meint einfach, dass man jetzt, wo Real Madrid öfter mit nur noch zwei zentralen Mittelfeldspielern spielt als vorher mit drei. Dass man da einfach nicht umhinkommt, öfter defensiv zu denken, auch mal in ein Kopfball-Duell zu geben. Da hat er ein bisschen gewitzelt mit mir. Offensiv ist es immer noch der genauso herausragende Kroos, wie schon die letzten Jahre, jetzt auch noch defensiv mitdenken und absolut respektiert in der Mannschaft.
Aber reicht das für die deutsche Nationalmannschaft?
Die Mentalität. Das reicht nur für Real Madrid.
Er ist auch nicht weiterentwickelt.
Also Didi Hamann hat mir gesagt.
Der Ironie-Detektor bricht hier gerade durcheinander. Ja, also nur falls noch immer noch vielleicht da draußen jemand denkt, ich glaube nicht, dass in der Rasenfunkzüberschaft jemand denkt, dass das mit dem Querpass, dass das noch irgendwie aktuell war oder jemals aktuell war. Nein, Toni Kroos wird in Spanien geliebt, auch von anderen Fanlagern, höchst genießt, höchsten Respekt. Alle beten dafür fast, dass er doch noch seinen Vertrag verlängert. Das ist ja immer noch offen und er lässt sich damit auch Zeit, auch zurecht, aber er ist mit 34 Jahren immer noch auch fit und frisch. Und wie gesagt, es macht ihm Spaß und selbst Zweikämpfe mittlerweile. Und hat er auch auf der PK gesagt von wegen, es gibt die Möglichkeit vom Nationalmannschaftstrainer und der denkt darüber nach. Also da muss man noch abwarten. Viele könnten sich vielleicht freuen, wenn er kommt. Ich glaube mir ist ein Geheimnis seiner letzten ein, zwei, drei Jahre, dass er noch mal besser ist. Und das ist eben auch, dass er diese Pausen bekommen hat. Und deswegen auch viel private Zeit hat mit seiner Familie und eben auch die Belastung besser steuern kann. Aber mal gucken, so eine Heimehm, vielleicht nimmt er die doch mit.
34 ist er kein Alter.
Also ich sag mal so.
Pepe wird jetzt bald 41, ja.
Als Nummer 4 kann man ihn doch mitnehmen. Hinter Goretzka, Kimmich, Gynurn. Warum denn nicht?
Ich dachte im Tor ein.
Vielleicht Pascal Groß, ja okay, vielleicht kämpft er mit Pascal Groß um einen zweiten Bankplatz. Aber warum denn nicht? Okay, Tronikos, sehr, sehr schöner MVP. Jetzt bin ich gerade, ja, wir müssen wieder in die Ligue 1 zurück.
Nein, England haben wir noch nicht.
England haben wir noch nicht, genau, danke, genau. Ich habe mich nämlich hier gefragt, warum ich das falsche Dokument offen habe. Danke, David, du bist der Einzige, der aufgepasst hat. Uli, wer ist dein MVP?
Wenn Nils einen nimmt, der immer hinten links schön reinfällt, um aufzubauen, nehme ich einen, der neuerlich hinten rechts reinfällt. Also, kein Poet des Weltfußballs, aber wahrscheinlich einer, der in die Nähe kommt, so Outdoor oder irgendwas. Martin Ödegård, nämlich von Arsenal, der mir gerade erstaunlich gut gefällt, der im Moment das verkörpert, was Arsenal gerade war in dem Jahr. Dann habe ich die nämlich auch schön mit untergebracht. 5 Siege in 5 Spielen erstmals in einem Kalenderjahr zum Auftakt. Der sorgt für viele, viele Bewegungen, wahnsinnig viele Rotationen, switcht noch nicht so sehr, wie ich es mir wünschen würde hier und da gegen tiefe Gegner, aber alles in einem, stellt 1 gegen 1 Situationen her, sehr, sehr passsicher, wahnsinnig einflussreich in der Offensive, gibt den schönen Fakt gegen West Ham beim 6-0. Ist er der erste Spieler in den Aufzeichnungen der Premier League gewesen, der es geschafft hat, 100 komplizierte Pässe hinzubekommen, mindestens 5 Torschossen kreiert hat und multiple Torbeteiligungen hatte und das in einem Premier League Spiel. Und das zeigt nochmal ganz gut, wie viel momentan über den läuft, auch wenn es jetzt am gestrigen Mittwochabend nicht so gut lief. Okay, das gehört dazu, glaube ich, zum Entwicklungsprozess bei Arsenal. Aber grundsätzlich ist er gerade zu einer leicht veränderten Rolle. Eben fällt jetzt etwas mehr zum Aufbau und dazu zu helfen. Und da gefällt er mir fast noch besser. Also recht viel mehr Entwicklungspotenzial kann es, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr geben bei einem einzigen Wunderkind.
Ja, genau, das ist nämlich das Ding. Da sieht man nämlich, manchmal braucht es einfach Zeit, selbst bei den hochtalentierten und hochgefeierten. Und das ist ja schön. Also ich zumindest finde das dann schön, wenn man solchen Spielern dann in der Mitte ihrer Karriere zuguckt. Und auf einmal sind die Versprechungen von früher eingetreten und dann auf einmal löst sich da was. Fast schon. Dann jetzt aber in die Liga. Ansan Hiro, David.
Mein Ansan Hiro ist Vincent Sierra. Der ist Kapitän von Toulouse, 28 Jahre alt. Und der ist unter anderem für mich der Ansan Hiro des vergangenen Spieltags, weil er Torschützer eines 30 Meter Freistoßes von Toulouse gegen Monaco war. Bei dem Monaco nur einen Mann in die Mauer gestellt hat, weil sie vermutlich davon ausgegangen sind, naja, aus der Entfernung wird er nicht aufs Tor schießen. Aber Sierra sagte anschließend, er hat gesehen, da sei Köhne aus dem Tor gegangen und da war Platz am ersten Pfosten. Und dann habe er ein bisschen geschauspielert und habe er absichtlich so getan, als hätte er sich in die andere Richtung geschaut und mit den Mitspielern kommuniziert, um da den Pass zu machen. Und dann hat er aber aufs Tor geschossen. Und damit hat Toulouse gegen Monaco gewonnen. Die Punkte können sie gut gebrauchen im Abschließkampf. Da habe ich ja gerade erwähnt, um den Relegationsplatz sehr eng zu. Die haben jetzt dreimal in Folge Ausplatz gewonnen. Monaco mit Hütte hat eine handfeste Krise am Hacken jetzt. Unter anderem dadurch, da das sieht nicht gut aus. Und Toulouse hat heute Abend ein durchaus wichtiges Europa League Spiel noch vor der Brust gegen Lissabon. Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt. Die haben das Auswärtsspiel verloren, aber die haben ja bekanntlich in der Hinrunde auch Liverpool zu Hause geschlagen. Immerhin mit 3 zu 2 in diesem Wahnsinnsspiel. Die sind ja auch überhaupt nur in dem Europa League Pokal mit drin, weil sie Pokalsieger geworden sind in Frankreich. Also sind jetzt keine Top-Mannschaft.
Jaja, stimmt. Ach, das ist immer so schön. Ihr sagt dann immer, gegen wen die im Europa-Pokal spielen. Dann erinnere ich mich wieder. Ah ja, stimmt. Da war ja was. Hab ich ja letzte Woche gesehen. Sind einfach zu viele Partien.
Die waren in einer Gruppe mit St. Giloise. Die sind der Grund, warum St. Giloise jetzt abgestiegen ist, in die Conference League.
Genau. Ja, genau. Es kommt jetzt alles wieder. Aus dem Rückenmark nach oben. Und eben gerade dieses Liverpool-Spiel. Geile Stimmung auch. Da kann man mal gespannt drauf sein. So, Serie A. Marius, wen magst du uns noch präsentieren?
Mein Anzang-Hero ist Riccardo Orsolini vom FC Bologna. Bologna-Saison ist hier, glaube ich, auch schon das ein oder andere Mal in dieser Saison besprochen worden. Ganz begeisternd. Und Orsolini ist, glaube ich, einer, der in Italien nicht so unter dem Radar fliegt. Der ist den Leuten schon bewusst, aber international kennen ihn, glaube ich, noch nicht so viele. Und er ist einer der absolut wichtigsten Spieler im System von Thiago Motta. Also alles, was in der Offensive da so passiert, geht irgendwann auf den rechten Flügel und über ihn. Also Spielmacher-Qualitäten technisch super stark, schnell auch massiv torgefährlich. Er ist jetzt in 21 Spielen bei 9 Treffern. Er hat die kleinere Krise, die sie zu Jahresbeginn hatten. Unter anderem durch seine Tore ist die überwunden worden. Wir haben jetzt wieder vier Ligaspiel in Folge gewonnen. Und ihm fehlen jetzt nur noch zwei Treffer, um seinen eigenen persönlichen Rekord aus der Serie A zu übertreffen. Das aus der Vor-Saison 11-Tore. Und wenn er sich nicht verletzt, dann schafft er das auf jeden Fall. Und ich hoffe, dass wir ihn mit Bologna und vielleicht dann ja auch noch mit Thiago Motta nächste Saison in der Champions-Liga erleben.
Da gerät man ins Träumen. Nils, wer ist dein Ansagen-Hero?
Ich bringe einen Trainer ins Spiel, der so ein bisschen aktuell sein eigenes Monster schafft. Denn Ernesto Valverde ist ja zurück beim Athletik-Club schon zum dritten Mal Trainer. Und ja, mittlerweile ist da – Athletik steht schon immer für Druck und Pressing und Leidenschaft. Und mittlerweile sind die auch noch effizient vorne und stehen weiter sicher hinten, obwohl sie in Diego Martinez den Abwehrchef von Vasa verloren haben. Also, die spielen eine überragende Saison mittlerweile. Die Williams-Brüder wissen jetzt auch endlich, wo das Tor steht. Die haben jetzt wieder einen neuen Mittelstürmer mit Guros Seta. Da war er lange nach Arizadouris Abgang. Gab es da Probleme? Und Valverde war auch letztes Jahr schon da. War lange, okay, gute Arbeit. Aber jetzt dieses Jahr sind es mal auch zwei Punkte aktuell hinter den Champions-League-Ringen. Da könnte noch was gehen hinter Atletico. Haben auch ein gutes Polster auf Real Sociedad dahinter. 9 Punkte. Das sieht gut aus. Sie haben jetzt im Copa-Halbfinale, da sind sie im fünften Jahr in Folge dabei. Haben sie im Hinspiel bei Atletico 1-0 gewonnen mit nur 30 Prozent Ballbesitz. Aber wie gesagt, das sind keine Mannschaften, die hinten drin stehen und mauern, sondern wirklich vorne drauf gehen. Die können wirklich unangenehm sein. Kein Team presst zu hoch und kann das auch 90 Minuten durchhalten in der Liga. Also da sind sie auf Kurs von ihrem dritten Finale in diesen letzten fünf Jahren und dann auch endlich den ersten Titel. Also da ist gerade Heimspiel im Saint-Mamès absolut sehenswert bei der Zone dort. Das sind absolute Festspiele immer. Und ja, macht einfach Spaß, da eine Mannschaft zu sehen, die mit offenem Visier ins Spiel geht. Trotzdem gerne auch mal die Null hält, weil sie hinten trotzdem konzentriert sind, aber vorne mittlerweile auch effizient sind. Und da eben, wie gesagt, Ernesto Valverde liefert da sehr, sehr gute Arbeit ab.
Krass auch, wie der sich entwickelt hat. Also ich glaube, nur vor ein paar Jahren hätten wir nicht gesagt, dass das Valverde-Fußball vorne drauf und Pressing, Pressing, Pressen und so weiter. Immer natürlich schon so ein bisschen. Aber ja, verrückt.
Nicht so wie aktuell, ja.
Aber absolut. Atletik. Sehr schön und Ernesto Valverde natürlich. Uli, dein Anzang Hero.
Ich will auch die drin haben. Tabellenführer in der Premier League. Wenn man über Liverpool spricht, also keine Angst, wird nicht Jürgen Klopp, aber dann würde man vermutlich viele, viele verschiedene Namen nennen. Was weiß ich, Mohamed Salah, Davin Lunes, Diogo Giotta, der sich jetzt leider schwer verletzt hat, letztes Wochenende. Van Dijk, keine Ahnung, wer mir sonst noch einfällt, aber ich möchte mal einen hervorheben, der stellvertretend steht für etwas, das ein Top-Team braucht, und zwar HW Elliott. Er ist mit 20 Jahren jetzt schon bei seinem 100. Premier League Spiel für Liverpool angekommen. Nur mal zum Vergleich, damit man es einordnen kann, scheint Alexander-Arnold und Gerard Wan 21, als sie diesen Meilenstein erreicht haben. Und Elliott ist in der Regel kein Stammspieler, und trotzdem gehört er zum Stamm, weil er eigentlich immer eingewechselt wird. Und weil er jetzt auch in der Zeit, in der Salah bei der African Cup of Nations war, zwar nicht zahlenmäßig ersetzt hat, definitiv nicht, das war dann eher die Jogo Jota, sondern weil er einfach mit seiner Reife, hat so ein Zocker-Gen in sich, traut sich viel zu, hat immer mal so einen ganz frechen Chip mit dabei, wird aber immer besser, kriegt es hin, dass er von der Bank Energie bringt, dass er dem Spiel so etwas wie Charakter sofort verleiht. Und ich glaube, so jemanden braucht man einfach im Team, eben genau, wenn es vor allen Dingen bei Liverpool gibt, es gibt ja viele Verletzungen in der Saison, insbesondere im Mittelfeld, da ist der zu nennen. Hätte auch Endo nehmen können, der gerade als Kopfballmonster in England aufwartet. Es ist erstaunlich, wie stark der da alles rausfischt. Ich hätte auch nicht gedacht, aber Harvey Elliott hat diese Award jetzt ausnahmsweise mal gegeben. Wie gesagt, stellvertretend für das, was ein Top-Team, meiner Meinung nach, braucht, so ein Supa-Sub, sagt man in England immer. Und das, glaube ich, ist er, ohne dass er jetzt die ganz großen Zahlen auflegt.
Dass der 100 Premier League Spiele für Liverpool gemacht hat, hätte ich nie im Leben gedacht. Nie im Leben. Das ist ja verrückt. Der wird ja einfach...
Er ist auch total crazy.
Seid er da, ist er einfach immer eingewechselt. Da musst du definitiv etwas haben, wenn das klappt. Sehr, sehr schöne Wahl. Dann noch die Momente der aktuellen Zeit, des Spieltags, wie auch immer euch beliebt. David, darf wieder beginnen.
Mein Moment des Spieltags ist die 88. Spielminute im Spiel Brest gegen Marseille, weil wir müssen auf jeden Fall noch mal zumindest kurz ein bisschen Brest erwähnen und loben. Da ist zu dem Zeitpunkt Brest nur noch zu Zehnt auf dem Platz, Zehn gegen Elf und Pierre-Lés Melou läuft in der gesamten Abwehr von rechts außen von Marseille vorbei und macht das Tor einfach selbst. Deswegen dann also der eingangs schon erwähnte Sieg von Brest gegen Marseille und wir haben jetzt über Marseille gesprochen, aber Brest nach wie vor auf Platz zwei. Das Fußballmärchen geht weiter. Alexi hat es auch bereits erwähnt letztes Mal, hat ja einen Schwerpunkt zu Brest. Das ist aber trotzdem schon einfach Wahnsinn. Und Lés Melou hat anschließend augenzwinkend in die Mikrofone gesagt, er hatte so eine Elfmetersituation in der ersten Hälfte und hat dann gesagt, der dann nicht gegeben wurde für Marseille und sagte dann, ja, also ich habe schon Angst gehabt, ich habe schon das Gefühl gehabt, dass das Elfmeter war, sagt wohl Gemäck, der Spieler, der gefault hat. Also holla, holla. Aber ja, sechs Punkte trennen Brest aktuell von Nicht-Europa-Plätzen.
Es geht einfach weiter. Ganz, ganz wunderbar. Marius, dein Moment des Spieltags.
Einer, der aus einer nicht so schönen Gegebenheit entstanden ist, aber das schließt sich dann irgendwie der Kreis für mich in dieser Ausgabe auch wieder einer fürs Herz ist nach dem ja doch sehr überraschenden Tod von Andy Brehme, ist das Echo, was es in Italien gegeben hat und die Ehrung seiner Person. Er hat ja für Inter gespielt zusammen mit Matthäus und Klinsmann Ende der 80er, Anfang der 90er. Das finde ich unglaublich, unvergleichlich. Also wie sehr er dort Legendenstatus genießt, ich glaube, das ist in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit gar nicht so bekannt. Thomas Hörner, den ich sehr schätze, der auch Inter-Tifo ist, hat in der SZ auch darüber geschrieben, falls ich das hier mal noch durchlesen möchte, Beppe Bergum, einer der größten Intelligenten, ist am Live-Mikrofon in den Gedanken daran, an Bremen, an die gemeinsame Zeit beendet habe, auch wenn er immer wieder Mailand besucht hat und dort auch im Stadion gefeiert wurde, was die da noch zusammen im höheren Alter erlebt haben, in Tränen ausgebrochen. Also für diese traurige Nachricht, was das für eine Reaktion hervorgerufen hat, finde ich bemerkenswert und sehr, sehr erwähnenswert.
155 Spiele für Inter, über 13.000 Minuten auf dem Feld gestanden. Also absolute Inter-Legende. Sehr schön ist der falsche Begriff, aber ich glaube, die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen, wie ich es meine. Sehr schöner Moment. Nils, es ist jetzt ein bisschen spät, danach zu kommen. Gebe ich zu, habe ich nicht darauf geachtet bei der Reihenfolge. Tut mir leid. Aber was ist dein Moment des Spieltags?
Ich dachte auch erst, nochmal den Athletik-Club zu nehmen. Da hatte Vivian im Topspiel gegen Girona das 3-3-Kurzverschluss auf der Linie abgewährt. Aber ich würde was Schönes nehmen aus der 3. Liga in Spanien. Die ist ja nicht ganz so professionell aufgestellt wie in Deutschland. Also die ist 2-klitrig mit 2 Gruppen. Und da gab es jetzt ein Spiel mit über 25.000 Zuschauern. Das war in Malaga. Den hatten wir vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt. Und da war zu Gast Recreativo. Also der Club aus Uelva. Das ist der älteste Club in Spanien, wo ich gerne mal bin. Da habe ich ein bisschen Verwandtschaft. Und das war eben für spanische Verhältnisse. Dritte Liga, über 20.000 Zuschauern. Das kommt in Malaga. Passiert schon mal auch bei Deportivo La Coruña. Aber eben dann nochmal 25.000. Das ist schon bemerkenswert, dass da eben so viel gute Stimmung war. Auch viele Auswärtsfahrer aus Uelva. Ist ja ein bisschen mal ein analogisches Derby natürlich gewesen. Das war für spanische Verhältnisse. War das sehr schöne Bilder aus dem La Rosa Leda. Und ja, kann man sich wünschen, dass solche Traditionsclubs wie Malaga Recreativo da mal wieder ein bisschen höher spielen. Zumindest mal 2. Liga, die sind aktuell 4. und 5. in dieser 2. Gruppe der 3.
Liga. 25.000, das ist schon nicht so schlecht. Habe mir gerade nachgeguckt. Drittligaschnitt in Deutschland lag letzte Saison bei 8.200. Gibt natürlich auch noch oben und noch unten.
Doch nur. Ich glaube, Spanien hat so 6.000, der Schnitt, die 3. Liga.
Da müsste ich jetzt noch mal im Detail reingucken. Man wird in diesem Jahr auf jeden Fall höher sein wegen der Absteige usw. Aber nur eben, um so grob das einzuordnen. Und dann haben wir noch einen Moment des Spieltags von Uli.
Ich nehme einen, der auch da wieder stellvertretend etwas Größeres zeigt. Eine kleine Präambel dazu. Rio Ferdinand hat vor zwei Wochen, glaube ich, in seinem TV-Interview gefragt worden, nach Weltklasse-Spielern, die es im Moment in England gibt. Und da hat er ein paar genannt, Phil Foden und so. Und dann hat irgendwann mal die Nachfrage seine Kollegin, die Monatoren gestellt, die da hieß, ja, und was ist denn mit Bukai Osaka? Und dann hat er gemeint, ne, der ist nicht Weltklasse. Und wie es dann der Zufall will, ist Rio Ferdinand gestern in der Maschine von London nach Porto, um ebenfalls wieder für die Champions League zu begleiten. Und es gibt wunderschöne Bilder von Fans, die den ganzen Linienflug über Rio Ferdinand bescheiden mit Bukai Osaka ist World Class. Und das liebe ich so an den Engländern. Das hat irgendwas Unaggressives in sich. Und trotzdem, sie können nicht aus sich raus, als ihm so zu sagen, und auch in eine schöne Art und Weise. Und das ist so der Fanatismus, den ich an den englischen Fußballfans insbesondere sehr schätze. Es ist nicht möglich, in London irgendwie durch die Straßen zu laufen. Und wenn die nur im Entferntesten mitkriegen, dass man irgendwas mit Fußball zu tun hat, dann hängen sie dir ein halbes Stunden Gespräche an und ich liebe das. Und deswegen ist das so mein Moment, der einfach nur mal ganz gut nachweist, wie es steht um Fußball in England. Ich glaube, das wird nicht so schnell aus der Kultur rausgehen.
Gott sei Dank. Wunderbar. Ein wunderbarer letzter Moment. Ihr vier. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Nils Kern, David Frogier de Ponlevoy.
Ich habe noch Spiele to watch. Ich wollte nur noch kurz einfach sagen, wer jetzt wegen Marseille kurz reinschauen möchte. Am Sonntag, 20.45 Uhr, spielt Marseille gegen Montpellier. Und außerdem, das eigentliche Top-Spiel ist L'Anse gegen Monaco, Sonntag um 13 Uhr. Und ich hatte kurz überlegt, ob ich L'Anse als Schwerpunkt mitbringe, weil ich war ja in L'Anse beim Freiburg-Spiel. Aber, und ich weiß, Max, du bist ja auch immer jemand, der gerne Podcasts, andere Podcasts empfiehlt. Ich habe einen L'Anse-Schwerpunkt gemacht für den Podcast Freiburg vergangene Woche, 13. Februar, mit einem Titel, der dir auch sehr gefallen wird, weil der Titel heißt eine Frage der Balance. Und genau, sie spielen jetzt am Wochenende gegen Monaco. Ich hoffe, dass sie sich dann erholt haben von dem hoffentlichen Niederlage gegen Freiburg heute Abend. Hüstel, Hüstel, Hüstel. Da wird übrigens auch, auch da wird der Rückgriff, sorry, das ist gerade verlängerer, aber es ist einfach zu viele schöne Fäden, die ich hier aufgreife. Da wird der aus Beke spielen, den ich erwähnt habe Anfang der Saison mal im Spiel. Da haben wir hier in Ligatour geredet, in welchen Ligen haben schon aus Beken gespielt, unter anderem in Lens.
Wie selten in so ratlose Gesichter geguckt, wie damals, als du diese Frage gestellt hast.
Also da wird Cousinow in der Innenverleihung spielen und genau. Lens hat heute Morgen, haben die Zeitungen gesagt, also es gab doch schon mal eine Situation, wo Lens im Hinspiel gegen Deutsche nicht so gut aussah. 1999 gegen Kaiserslautern und da haben sie 4 zu 1 gegen Kaiserslautern im Rückspiel gefahren.
Du bist der Beste. Ich mache heute Abend erst in Lens. Du bist der Beste.
Okay, Gott sei Dank haben wir jetzt noch die Matches to Watch mit dabei. Hat irgendjemand sonst noch ein Match to Watch, was er loswerden will? Jetzt kann ich es ja nicht abwirken. Ja, Nils meldet sich schon.
Sergio Ramos Rückkehr ins Stadio Santiago Bernabéu nach über 3, 4 Jahren Sonntagabend. Ja, mal tritt gegen den FC Sevilla. Das könnte lustig werden.
Der will treffen. Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn Uli das auch macht. Nein, er bleibt ruhig.
Nö, ich habe gerade überlegt, ob wir uns nochmal treffen. Bis zum, ich glaube, 9. der 3. oder 8. der 3. ist dann das Datum für ein letztes Mal Jürgen Klopp gegen Manchester City. Das sollte man schon sehen. Das ist ja fast dann schon ein Nostalgiefaktor. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir uns bis dahin nochmal sehen, hören. Aber ansonsten würde ich das schon mal vorsichtshalber nahelegen.
Ja, absolut. Das nehmen wir schon mal auf die Liste. Und Marius, gibt es in der Serie A noch was, auf das wir blicken sollten?
Nicht ganz so groß wie die Rückkehr von Sergio Ramos zur Real. Aber Charles de Quetellare spielt mit Atalanta am Sonntagabend und 20.45 Uhr bei Milan. Da lief es ja für ihn gar nicht gut. Jetzt bei Atalanta ist er richtig gut. Und ich glaube, das könnte ein ganz ansehnliches Fußballspiel werden.
Sehr gut. Ich dachte, du kommst mit Juve gegen Frau Sinone. Aber auch das…
Ja, also warum nicht?
Bist du auch einer Ligre Versteher, wie ich das dann erinnere?
Das führen wir demnächst mal aus. Vielleicht machen wir mal so eine Gruppentherapie-Sitzung. Dann könnt ihr das einfach mal ausdiskutieren. Ihr sehr, ihr A-Experten. Ihr vier, es war wie immer ganz, ganz fantastisch von euch. Ich werde mit euch, ich werde alles verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann und so weiter. Ich habe mir hier mal eifrig notiert, wenn wir irgendwas angesprochen haben. Das heißt, es wird auch Links geben, die wir hier erwähnt haben. In den Show Notes, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Danke an Nils Kern, David Frogier de Ponlevoy, Marius Soyke und Uli Hebel. Danke euch vier. Das ist wie, wenn der Lehrer guten Morgen sagt. Und ich danke auch allen Hörerinnen und Hörern und allen Supporterinnen und Supportern. Der Rasenfunk ist allein crowdfinanziert. Keine Investoren hier, außer euch. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich danken Henry, Daniel, Boivot, Patrick E. Chancentot, Mattes und Paladinus. Sie alle haben uns nicht nur unterstützt, sondern sich auch als Supporterinnen registriert, damit ich sie hier nennen kann. Auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und auf rasenfunk.de findet ihr noch ganz, ganz viele andere Folgen. Hört unbedingt rein. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.